you know your journey
from from when you started to now like
the perseverance like was there ever a
point in time where you were like
you were questioning like this music
[ __ ] like whether or not you could
actually do it like and make a living
off of it like were you wasting your
time
you know it was crazy when i was younger
and when i first met light and [ __ ] when
we first started doing it
we went through the artist development
stage and at that stage i
believed in myself so much i had so much
confidence like
it's going to happen regardless
regardless but then
you know it started becoming work you
know
it was like dude you have to do this
it's it's promoting yourself as get and
back then we were still going
door-to-door selling tickets
and cds out the trunk type [ __ ] like we
were still doing that we got the end of
that
you know what i'm saying so it was it
was it was a lot of work that had to be
done so
i i honestly was more motivated
then like as far as i knew i was gonna
make it and then after it popped off i
kind of got discouraged
because then the real work started then
it was like damn this
is like the big leagues you know it's
not you can't just do what the [ __ ] you
want no more sometimes
sometimes you got to play the game you
know what i'm saying so
but but you know now i've i've i've had
you know
four years seeing how almost where
you're seeing how the big leagues work
you know and it's kind of like that
phase again i'm getting that that oh
okay like you got to chip on your
shoulder again yeah
it's it's weird like i have i don't know
i always knew though i always told my
mom when i was a kid i said mom
i'm going to make it in music right and
my mom was
she's the reason she is my musical i
have a music influence
so i always told her that and i i knew
it i
i knew i was going to make it i didn't
know how or what was
it was going to take but i just knew it
and then you know it took a lot
yeah so the things you're talking about
where it felt like music started to be
work i feel like i go through this a lot
with talking to artists where it's like
you know what are the
what are those things that you started
to have to do because i think that what
you did a great job of is
building with your fan base converting
them to like hardcore fans
and i know a lot of that is work it's
replying to comments it's dm'ing people
this
what were those things that you could
talk about that you actually had to
start doing that were like
that maybe like an artist who's watching
this might want to start [ __ ] doing
yeah yeah um the main thing which is
something i still have a problem with
because i'm not like a
a social media person the main thing is
honestly
posting that product every day and and
if you don't have a fan base
if you if if you're posting every day
the same thing they know say you're
dropping a song every week
if if people know you're dropping a song
every week
that people have something to tell
people you know what i'm saying and that
spreads and if it's good ass music
it's gonna you know boom
but the thing that you have to do is you
have to be consistent
you have to show your face like light
used to always say you know
out of sight out of mind facts you know
what i'm saying and that was one of the
things like me and him used to argue all
the time because i'm like man i'm not a
social media person i don't want to post
you know but but then he'll tell me to
post and i'll post and
you see all the interaction i'll be
happy like